at the port of banjo a few ships
dock waiting for cargos
shipping activities may not be near what
the government expects after covered 19
disruptions
but for modular minsanian who runs a
seafood export company
it's an encouraging sign he says for
businesses like his to remain afloat
they need support so if we get crawlers
and we get
help from government like let's say sort
of a loan sort of a grant
you'll be able to purchase a lot of fish
and be able to present it i'm selling it
locally
within the stop region on the still
waters of oyster creek
dozens of boats anchored are waiting for
tourists
but only a few of them came
la min quinte is hoping to convince some
of them to ride in his boat
when we arrived he was happy to show us
the creek and the river gambia
the waterways he says would have been
bustling with tourists
now hope is the only thing left for the
industry
we have uh thousands of uh employees
who are right now late and then at home
so basically most of the
places are also closed due to maybe
rent issues and other financial issues
so completely it is um
it is it is it is completely a difficult
situation at the moment
gambia lost 40 million dollars in
tourism revenue
in 2020 for a small economy
that's devastating the senegambia
quarter is one of the best places to
assess the health of the gambian economy
on a normal day this area
in the heart of the country's tourism
industry will be filled with tourists
and those who cater for them now that
number
has significantly reduced
business leaders here say economic
activities may be resuming slowly
but recovery is still far off it has not
ended
but there is some progress and recently
i'm pleased to see the chamber
who said it's street fair gambia
international after
two years he says one out of three
businesses here in the gambia
may not survive the pandemic and one out
of six businesses that do survive
are expected to face long-term cash flow
problems
that could mean more job losses or
outright closures
for some while some businesses in europe
and asia are beginning to recover from
covered 19 disruptions
remittance from gambians living abroad
accounting for over 20 percent of the
gdp
is not expected to return to its
pre-covered 19 levels
that means more uncertainties for
families
and the economy of the gambia ahmeditris
al-jazeera banjo